you see that thing Paul though in the UK
they've Incorporated love bombing into
what can now be called coercion so
basically what is love Bobby is being
nice
[Laughter]
in America put them all in jail yeah
yeah and so I was just like this is all
crazy yeah but you're right about
Zoomers though because I I saw a stat I
think Chris Williamson posted a start
earlier but it was something ridiculous
like it was something like 18 of
effectively Zoomers think that asking a
woman out for a drink is always
harassment or something like that it was
it was just it was just news it has to
be some better codes
behind a screen right there's so much
behind their phone and everything that
they're just like oh now like yeah being
a human is illegal I know yeah it's like
women we're
like think about this we pick husbands
who you spend the next 50 years of your
life with probably the most important
decision we can make who we reproduce
with we pick off of horoscope signs
[Laughter]
and I'm just like okay should we be
should we trust us so now let me get
this straight the politicians have to
ask the women who don't pay the majority
of the taxes who don't do the majority
of the work they have to cater to us and
what we want when this is our track
record of decision making we've had more
decisions to make in a hundred years and
we've chosen to be [__]
[__] and I'm like okay so we're gonna
say they get to pick who gets the nuke
button
it's almost like you would you would
elect someone or get someone out of
office because they say mean words and
put someone with dementia and you know
I'm not gonna
[Laughter]
yesterday
women should not you're biting guy no no
no I was like I'd have to disassociate
but
[Laughter]
um yeah it's it's God damn dude that's
it's so crazy I mean all there's so much
bad [__] going on but at the same time
too it's also these evil people at top
as well there's it's these one
percenters of one percenters at the top
that allowed this form of college it's
just to allow I mean they allowed like
they I mean it's not the it's not the
scientist fault that they created the
the Plan B pill and they created the you
know the uh what's called the birth
control pill it's these evil agencies
within either the government or within
like you know these whatever these one
world order people that pushed out this
[__] during the 60s and the 50s and the
70s and stuff to be out there everywhere
playing and do a plan B used to you know
what plan B really what it was it was to
control the black population seriously
oh yeah the n-word project yeah Margaret
Sanger that [__] and you know the crazy
thing is all of these studies
departments the women's studies they
literally hide history if you request
certain documents that like ask you who
you are they won't give it to you yes
yes because this is what they say they
say we're going to rewrite like we're
basically going to read history from the
like from the point of view of the
oppressed so what is what is that switch
it because now you're they don't believe
the writings of the women at the time
they don't believe any of the historical
evidence it's like no we're gonna put
our spin on history and not make it real
history yeah and the women's studies
Department they'll like hide Margaret
sanger's like racist rants yeah Oliver
racist [__] they just hide it's it's
it's it's crazy as [__] and stuff like
that and then on top of that there's
this whole like I mean this is this is
mixing the red pill in with the
Conspiracy Theory with like crypto but
like they've been I mean we know we all
know this [__] they've been trying to
control the global population for a
[__] long time now this and it's
really messed up they started with the
Afro-American Community let's not even
talk about all these freaking vaccines
now I'm not talking about the ones that
happened recently I'm talking about way
back in the day that they're infecting
people they were literally affecting
people with like tuberculosis and all
this crazy ass crap to get people sick
to kill them off and then I mean even
the Germans the Germans were using these
these machines and stuff on um the
Jewish people as well as Gypsies and
people that they didn't like so they
would imagine like they make their own
Planned Parenthood you'd come in there
they would have like a basically a
radiation machine kind of like a set
like this yeah they would turn it on and
you would be standing in line and they
you couldn't have kids anymore and that
[__] is real the Germans did that so
there is some [__] up [__] 80 of
planned parenthoods are in minority
neighborhoods why 80 still to this day
think about this okay we will cancel
Nike or whatever store for having racist
Roots but the black population would be
double today if it wasn't for Planned
Parenthood and so it's like they
literally said we're gonna try to
control the black population and they're
doing it and nobody cares yet they'll
cancel Nike or whatever Corporation it
is for its racist founder racist Roots
but it's like someone that's committing
a genocide in front of our eyes they
don't don't care now I gotta say this
right now right now I see the [__]
they're starting to do this with the
Latino population right now and I I put
now I I'll just say this right now
they're starting to like Pro for the
first time they're trying to prop up
some of these Latino artists and put
them up and stuff and a lot I mean who's
the most popular one they popped up
recently is Bad Bunny and he's this dude
this dude
no she's like she's black she's like
she's like yeah she's mixing stuff but
she's like looking pretty bad
no makeup and stuff and like no hair and
everything like that and then now she's
trying to put herself up and stuff but
hey no hating right but no like we had
people like you know like um I mean we
were starting to have some of these
Latino artists come up and stuff and
they're being they're like it's almost
going like humiliation rituals and stuff
but I'll have these dudes are like
dressing in their music videos in ladies
clothes and this was like and this is
the people that like Bad Bunny and stuff
like I actually like Bad Bunny when he
started off and then as soon as he
started popping they put him in dresses
he starts wearing [__] like colored
[__] nails and stuff it's just and
like what are they trying to do because
they're starting to destroy the family
structure of Latino families and stuff
we have a like a machismo culture where
the man the man's The Breadwinner we
have the woman supposed to stay at home
because I have a bunch of kids and
they're coming after this because what
we're like 30 of the [__] population
right now we're heading for 50 and
they're like oh we need to slow this
[__] down
and how do they do it women because
we're idiots we're dummies it's Bad
Bunny still like wearing dresses well
not now but but he's yeah he sometimes
wears them you know you know it's a big
red pill for me I was like oh my God
part of the depopulation agenda was
women's sports when I started looking
into women yeah because it makes you why
do you think we got all these dikes that
are like yeah yeah why do we got all
these like lesbian chicks in the WNBA in
the women's soccer why do we have these
women that because working out like men
raises our testosterone
it does and it makes you more masculine
and then I look at is that because of
competition well I don't know why
exactly I just talked to like a hormone
doctor and he like I guess women are
only supposed to work out like two weeks
out of the month or something like
there's some
I don't understand I don't really
understand it I just was talking to this
hormone doctor and he said yeah and the
crazy thing is if you um a lot of people
that are trans the issue is actually
their hormones and he would detransition
people like people like basically he
would check out a girl like would come
in and say she thought she was a d
transition yeah like she thought she
wanted to change genders and it turns
out she just had high testosterone or
low testosterone for males so it's part
of it and like the thing about
volleyball is it's very much very
feminist and a lot of feminists like run
all of this stuff and so it's like and I
was thinking about this I'm like
literally
like the the volleyball pipeline is like
you play until you're 30 35 and then you
know make no money right and you make no
money yeah and I was thinking I'm like
how silly is it I'm like I spent my
early 20s chasing a career that makes
zero dollars
like men would never no it was a lot of
fun and I loved it but it's like weird
looking back it's like literally travel
volleyball
a month you spend like two I spent two
to four hours a day like working out
since I was like 12 years old and yeah
and so I was just thinking about it and
I'm like it's and it's all by like
lesbians that run a lot of this stuff
and like yeah and then and then it's
like your family is the team it's not
your actual family no no who's getting
quite big now isn't it women soccer
starting to make some money apparently
yeah yeah
not really you know I mean I would
guarantee I would be really surprised if
they don't operate at a loss the only
way I see women's sports making money is
if they do it off of social media and
like have the girls be like social media
influencers get some drama in there yeah
yeah or maybe you know in sexuality like
that
athlete and uh she gets a little there's
one girl there's like a gymnast yeah
she's really cute and then she gets a
lot of stick because I was like oh
people only like her because she's hot
well yeah
but it's like when you think about it
that whole industry it's like an
industry that's subsidized meaning like
the majority of it operates at a loss
like we don't have the demand for it and
it really just makes us into men yeah
like that's that's not even taking
nothing from like Serena Williams
because she's like the most dominant
like basically person in like 10 in
women's tennis but she even she admits
she will get destroyed by a top 300 guy
yeah because she has the guy was
hungover the guy was hung over here
people were not shocked that he lost
people are shocked that he he scored a
point on her that she scored a point on
him so it was that's the kind of stuff
we're talking about but like Serene I
don't know Serena she actually was like
she admitted it and stuff she's like oh
yeah
and so what was that guy from the 70s
again that tennis player like uh he was
always kind of like controversial or
whatever Mcenroe exactly like I mean he
was getting a lot of [__] for saying
that uh like yeah Serena if she were to
play a man right she would she would
probably have a lot of trouble she would
lose she's even admitted that before and
then they you know there's a clip of
basically Serena saying exactly that
yeah and then on a talk show right on a
talk show and then they crucify him for
it right you know and it's just like
people want to live in a fantasy land
you know it's like well women want to
live in la la land
between the feminists is there a
conflict between the feminists and the
trans people coming into the the sport
though because he wasn't the family so
hang on a minute these people are coming
into our
you know yeah what do you think that we
just did a tournament I I didn't
actually play in it but I went to watch
because I forgot to register in time but
yeah there is a bunch of the [__] it
was like an all nations turn oh yeah in
England there's an all nations
tournament and um for whatever reason
why does Brazil have so many trans
people they like it was like Brazil in
the Philippines I'm like what is going
on the music I'm telling you they're
using the music to hit the Latino
Community I'm telling you episodes yes
yeah they are little yeah probably the
surgery is quite cheap over there as
well if you fancy gonna get done yeah
you can get a job but it's like in the
music
that is literally lyric that's what
they're doing it's it's really strange
[__] I mean I've talked about this
before in the past like the reason that
like we haven't been infected with
lesbians too much at least in the
Mexican Community is because we we used
to have a star it's really sad you got
killed by lesbian women and this Selena
Selena what Selena like her basically
her manager or not a manager but her
like her fan club manager basically was
stealing money and promising hey um like
they say Pearl's gonna shut the this
event and stuff and then she was taking
money from like you know regular people
and stuff like that and then what
happened is this lesbian she was about
to get fired she pulled the gun she shot
Solana and she died right well because
um in the Mexican media they they played
out that she was this angry lesbian
chick or something like the Latinas the
Mexican Latinos [__] hate lesbians so
like we saved ourselves one cycle but
I'm starting to see that creeping up now
because they're pushing in Puerto Rico
one of some of the hottest two of the
hottest songs were basically made by
these these bases of these lesbian
chicks are all talking about the you
know the best kind of chicks of the
chicks you can kiss and that this is
like literally the lyrics that are
blasting I couldn't escape it kissed a
girl
it's like and we're banned sorry but
like yeah but that's what's going on
right is and but they're pushing this
crazy that was in Puerto Rico I can't
imagine what they're playing right now
in like Brazil right now uh it's got to
be something because there is a bunch of
them from Philippines was the worst that
was the most not Thailand no it was the
Philippine team that was like I think
four or five on the court were dudes
damn yeah did you guys ever have a
chance of beating or they were just
destroying you no they weren't even they
were like kind of like it was kind of
weird because if they did something too
masculine they'd like hold back uh you
could like see you know what I mean I
would hope they'd hope yeah they're
clearly not the most athletic guys
so true women yeah
I don't know but that was yeah and you
know it's crazy I was tweeting about it
and they pulled up a tweet where I said
um oh no the [__] have like made it
to England and that like volleyball
England messaged me and basically like
said this is a transphobic tweet and I
was confused because I had a different
tweet that said I'm afraid of trans
people so I was like I don't know why
you'd pick that one
and it was crazy because yeah I'm
supposed to get like a disciplinary so I
don't really care they could kick me out
but it's it's just crazy because even
like talking about it we got now these
wokies are trying to tell me I can't
complain right I mean they don't like
freedom of speech yeah they're only
famous speech and stuff but I'm telling
you the best thing you can do right now
is um in major sports is BET on the
males playing in the female sports you'd
make a fortune I'm telling you right now
it's there's so much money Sports I mean
it would be mostly what like there's
soccer there's a bit baseball there's
actually a lot of fighting Sports
actually you're having a lot of like
these mixed martial arts I haven't seen
it in the Years really yeah there's a
there's a ton of women that are getting
their ass
be bad I'm talking about like bloody
like [__] up and stuff like that
there's a lot of those weird ones with
track for some reason track's another
big one where you have a lot of males
come in swimming swimming's another
tournament my friend said she like hurt
her finger because the Dude like hit so
hard really dang yeah she'll be all
right but
but yeah but there's like there's
stories of this stuff where like they
have some of these and I'm not trying to
make this whole stream about this but
like you've had some of these you know
these uh these some of these people come
into these events and there's some women
have been training their whole life and
they they've missed the opportunity to
go to the next level or to go to D1 or
something or whatever the hell it is and
what what the [__] you know and it's so
sad because we literally trained like I
can even count like there was maybe like
three really important like moments in
my career that like I think I went to
the ncaas twice I went to State once and
it's like we'll train our whole lives
like 12 15 years
for like a couple moments yeah it's like
you're taking away like we barely we
don't even get money we like barely have
anything you can't give us something
yeah like do you guys sell Girl Scout
cookies to pay for everything
no it's usually like taken from the men
subsidized like most women's sports
operates at a loss I'd be I'd be really
surprised if women women's soccer
operates at a profit I'd be surprised